well commuting and I'm really glad you
could join us today so um so you know
today you're the head of I do research
and when the Chinese government the
government of China was looking for
someone to start up and build a national
deep learning research lab they tapped
you to help start this thing so you know
arguably I think maybe other number one
deep learning person in the entire
country of China so before so I'd love
to ask you a lot of questions about your
work but before that I want to hear
about your personal story so how do you
end up yeah I'm getting to do this work
that you do yeah so so I actually I
before my ph.d program my major was in
kind of optics so it's more like in
physics I think I had a fairly good
color background like very good Packer
on math the outer I can do us and I was
thinking like what kind of major gonna
take for my ph.d program and I was
thinking that well I guess go for a
vertex are go for something else because
a black to like early 2000 I think not
new technology was really really hot
yeah and but I was thinking probably I
should look at something like a even
more exciting and the leaves a good
chance that I I was taking some classes
that you pay and I got to know Tenley
so later he became my PhD advisor so and
I was thinking like machine learning was
a great thing to do and I got really
excited and I kind of I changed my major
so I I did my hippie idea open like a
majoring in like in machine learning
yeah and so let that kind of lecture is
I was left for five yes and then I was
kind of really exciting and I think I
got I learned lots of being from scratch
Hey well good and even like a pcasi I
didn't I didn't know Louis before yeah
it was kind of I feel I was learning new
things every day so he was very very
exciting experience for me this was one
of those things of a lot of stars
although you know just did a lot of work
and
was underappreciated for this time right
right yeah so I think and she was
exciting place and I I was that at
beginning as a researcher I mean I I
also like to feel that wow I learned
lots of things and and I just laser
energy I kind of started working on
computer vision I actually started
working on communism very late compared
I mean relatively late yeah and the
first thing i did was i participated in
image in a challenge that's your first
year of image net challenge i was kind
of a managing a team to work on a
project
it was lucky we're quite lucky later we
were quite strong and and we at the end
we actually got the number one place
overwhelming number one place you know
in the context so you're the first ever
in the world in which their competition
with like yeah and i was the prisoner
did a presentation at the level shop
yeah so i was always really nice
appearance for me and that actually gave
me into Lisa well Alaska computer vision
tasks yeah and and so I had been working
on Lisa well a skill Robin since they're
like yeah and so when he least your cat
Haven New York time cat they come out
and also later like at least Alex nekima
you really broke my mind I try I think
it's not on oh wow the tubulin is so
powerful and and and I think since then
I think West LA so I for I think to work
on laws so as a head of China's National
Lab
national research that want deep
learning there must be a lot of exciting
activities going on there so for the for
the global audience you're watching this
what should they know about what's
happening with this National Lab the
mission awful is a national engineering
lab which to build a really large deep
learning platform and probably over to
be the biggest one at least the biggest
one in China and unleased perform we
would offer people like a deep learning
framework like pedal
and we offer people last well a scale
computing a resource and also other
people will hatch like well it big data
right and and if people are able to kind
of develop our research or develop a
kind of good technology on this platform
we're all so awful and like a big
applications so formally the technican
be probably into some big applications
if I do so later the technology up get
insulate and improved yeah so so we
believe that the combining loss of a
kind of a combining loss will be sauce
altogether I think is gonna be a really
powerful a profile and also give you one
example is for example like right now if
we publish a paper say little researcher
published a paper if someone want to
reproduce it and the needle cannot the
best thing to do in probably the person
who produce provided up the color
somewhere and you could tell no like all
the 2-yard it were computer and you also
try to find that the date has said
somewhere and and that we probably don't
you probably also need to get a good
comic relation of your kind of
completing this awesome long and
smoothly right so it should be easily
kind of taking some efforts at the
leisure tip National Lab things will
become much easier so so if we someone
using this platform to write a paper to
do the work and I buy the paper and the
lay who have look code on a unleash on
this profile and and the computing
structure is already set up follow for
this code and a date has led to so
basically you just need a common line to
Lee producer Lisa so this is a huge I
think is a big big a kind of belief of a
lot of a kind of reproducibility she was
in computer science so you easily we
just kind of just a few seconds you
start learning something like you see in
a paper yeah so Liz Cheney powerful so
we so this is just one example we we are
working on like it to make sure that we
are providing providing like a very
powerful platform a tulip community and
tuna industry that's amazing that really
speed up even
yeah can you um give a sense of how much
measles is you know the Chinese
government is putting to thank you for
this deep learning National Lab so I
think Alicia national engineering lab I
think the government that we can invest
some funding into here to build up
infrastructure but I think I'm more
important with the be a least gonna be a
flagship inviting in China gonna lead a
loss of kind of people in the efforts
like including like a national project
and and and the loss of kind of policies
and things yeah so Lisa actually is
Cheney powerful and I think of app idea
we are really honored to get in his life
you know someone at the heart of deep
learning in China and so there's a lot
of activity in China that the global
audience you know isn't aware of here
then hasn't seen yet so what should
people outside China know about deep
learning in China yeah I think in China
especially in the past few years I think
the C de belem empowered a product
service is really booming like coming
like ranging from like a search engines
to like a face no condition to like to
surveillance to like a ecommerce like
lots of praise I think that they are
investing big ever in the deep learning
and also like they are really make it
yourself it was technology to make the
business much more powerful yeah and and
the this actually is a very important
for for for developing AI technology in
general I think for myself I and also
lots of people Shelley's we will believe
that actually it's well in Holland to
how Lisa we often call the puzzle group
but for example you you you probably
when we start out to think of buildings
and technology that we have some initial
data and we try to do our initial
algorithm they would launch is an
initial product right
for the our service the other letter
would get the data front users and in
the other weekend model has no developer
more will deliver more solid we would
develop better algorithms because we see
Monday how we know like a will be a
better algorithm so we have more data
and better algorithm were able to have
better technology for a product service
and then definitely we hope it will be
able to achieve more users right because
the product that I know it's better and
and they will get more data so this is a
really good positive loop and he's very
special I sheriff or for AI related
technologies right I mean for all for
like its traditional thing not like a
laser like a laser that I was working I
left before so
so it isn't isn't more like it it look
closer but I'm not gonna be more linear
but the vault this AI technology
actually because of this positive loop
you can imagine that definite certain
part you'll come with like really fast
girls are full of Technology yeah
and in the least actually super
important and when we designing a
research research interim with only
desire handy but we work on the
direction that we able to get to Nisha
quick kind of improving period right if
we are not able to even our business i
evil to the whole kind of our whole
business is not able to fund this
positive loop even if we are not able to
fund is this it has strong positive loop
then did this direction probably should
not work out because someone else who
holds down business too funny strong
loop let me get to Lisa kind of a phrase
much more quicker than you are so so so
this actually when important logic for
for us when we looking at the legacy hey
you need a company what direction we
should work on at what direction should
not work our wisdom is a winning point
of fact I wasn't okay today both in
China and in the US and globally there
are no other people wanting to enter a
deep learning and wanting to enter AI
but what advice would you have for
someone that wants to get into this
field so another day is definitely I
think people who start with a
was open salsa friend looks I think
unless Cheney powerful to convince the
others I think when I was studying my
deep learning a study there was not much
like a oven sauce the sauce I think
nowadays like in India especially in
tabular knee
he's a very good community and all that
right and they are multiple like a
really good people and in frameworks
it's always like that I got tension flow
a cafe like now I call coffee to write
and I've got in China we had a good pedo
pedo and the closer I under in even like
Formosa follows online they a lot like a
causes to continue to teach you how to
use those and and also nowadays also the
other many like a publicly available
pinch mark and the people whose see hey
I can really kind of skill for really
spilling people like how how well they
could do a lot benchmark so so so
basically time to get familiar with the
deeper learning I think those are very
good a starting point
how did you gained an understanding so
actually I do it you know obviously the
way I kind of learned I'm long TCA I
learned like I'd be almost like a
develop learning actually right so and
so so basically I so I inside also is a
good way I feel like we cannot lay down
lots of foundations right and we learn
graphic your mother alright so so these
are all kind of alright right now
he didn't expand a little bit but
annoying laws I should give you was a
good intuition about how deep learning
works and in the one day probably is a
connection of deep learning to loss like
a framework or approach I think the
ladies already lost our connections and
the laws actually make deepening which
always out to India and yeah so I feel
like a good stylist a open source
alongside to finish cheney powerful
resource but mingle allows
suggest like a you also didn't learn
those basic things about machine
learning so thank you that was fast even
though I've known you for a long time
there are a lot of details you're
thinking that I didn't realize until now
so thank you very much thank you so much
for having me